on this Friday night Russia's annexation
Proclamation moscow's illegal land grab
of four Ukrainian regions
keeves next move that could infuriate
the Russian president in this escalating
War remembering residential school
victims and survivors and a horrible
chapter of Canadian history I'm here to
walk from my father and my grandmother
the second national day for Truth and
Reconciliation Warriors against violence
you know it's always the ones that love
us that we always hurt one group's
mission to help indigenous peoples heal
and new States same hurricane
Ian Kareem's into the Carolinas
foreign
assar
good evening and thank you for joining
us on this Canada's second official
national day for Truth and
Reconciliation
it's a day to understand a dark
disturbing part of our history and the
tragedies that took place in
institutions known as residential
schools it's a day to honor the
survivors and the children who never
returned home but it's also a day to
understand the multi-generational trauma
their families and Indigenous
communities still face to this very day
this is not a radical concept
to pause and to reflect
you do so for other days and occurrences
throughout your life quite routinely
on November 11th for example you wear
your puppy
today many people wore orange at events
held right across the country to Mark
the national day for Truth and
Reconciliation today is also orange
shirt day an indigenous lead Grassroots
movement that started in 2013.
many say we need truth before
reconciliation and today is an important
part of that our Abigail Beeman was at a
special event that also took place in
our nation's capital to Mark the day of
remembrance and has our top story
tonight
starting at Parliament Hill a two
kilometer March led by survivors full of
meaning and emotion I'm glad that my
friend came to pick me up and bring me
here because I don't think I could have
come alone
I'm here to walk for my father and my
grandmother to be here it's just
overwhelming and
it's sad but you know it's uh it's a
really good feeling and every time I
spoke my massive language I will get hit
look a big stickler there Brian Joseph
Norman came from Winnipeg he wants
people to know he was sexually abused as
a young boy at residential school this
walk this day is part of his healing
Journey I'm honored that to have really
uh appreciate that
how much um
people are starting to listen yeah to
our stories and that's the Hope here
that with more non-indigenous people in
the crowd and more attention to
indigenous issues in light of the
suspected unmarked Graves found at
residential schools the journey towards
reconciliation may move faster the heavy
grief that we've all felt across Turtle
Island what they're your first Nations
indigenous or non-indigenous we all love
our children only a small number of the
94 calls to action from The Truth and
Reconciliation Commission have been
enacted if we go at this rate it's going
to take us 40 years to fulfill all of
those calls to action which is not
acceptable along the Route and then at
the afternoon program this Banner with
the names of more than four thousand
children who died at residential schools
so long it took about three dozen people
to carry it we must all recognize that
the Indian residential school system is
not just something for your history
books
it is something that indigenous peoples
are still feeling the effects of each
and every day the Prime Minister among
those to lay a pair of shoes on stage he
attended events in Two Cities unlike
last year when he drew criticism for his
vacation with family in Tofino BC I hate
your residential school I hate you
you're a monster you're a monster built
to devour innocent native children a day
to focus on children and survivors and
look to the future of reconciliation
Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa
and today it can be triggering for some
people so if you're looking for help you
can call the residential school
survivors and family crisis line at
1-800-721-0066
the war in Ukraine has entered a
dangerous and unpredictable new phase
Russian President Vladimir Putin walked
into a packed Hall at the Kremlin and
declared illegal annexations of four
regions in Ukraine 18 of the country to
compare that's about the size of the
island of Newfoundland in an elaborately
staged speech Putin called the Sham
referendums held in Ukraine the will of
millions of people and accused the west
of waging a hybrid war against Russia
Canada and the U.S are now hitting
Russia with new sanctions Putin says the
four occupied territories that you see
here donesque lujans Curson and
zappariza are now part of Mother Russia
even though Russia doesn't hold full
control over any of them and Putin says
he will defend the four Eastern regions
as if they were part of his country
Ukrainian Military Intelligence claims
the risk of Russia using nuclear weapons
is now very high and Ukrainian president
vlodimir zielinski is now moving to Fast
Track an application for Ukraine to join
NATO as Redmond Shannon reports these
events Mark a further escalation in the
conflict and before we go to the story
we want to warn you some of the images
might be disturbing
a civilian Convoy blown to pieces this
rocket strike in a Ukrainian held part
of the disputed zaparisia region killed
at least 30 people Friday many more were
injured
those killed including children were
about to cross into russian-held
territory according to Ukrainian
officials they were delivering Aid and
picking up relatives for family
reunifications as ever both sides in the
war blaming the other the timing of the
deadly attack perhaps telling
in Moscow Vladimir Putin flanked by the
Russian installed leaders of four
Ukrainian regions including zaparita a
red square rally to celebrate their
annexation despite Russia not fully
controlling any of the regions
yeah
yeah it comes three days after so-called
referendums in the regions where
moscow-backed authorities declared
landslides in favor of joining Russia
there are reports some voters were
forced to cast their ballots at gunpoint
the process and results condemned as
Shams by the West on Friday Canada the
U.S and others imposed new sanctions on
Russia and russian-backed officials in
Ukraine
subject to legal and parliamentary
approval Moscow now considers the areas
Russian soil President Vladimir Putin
used the occasion to repeat a thinly
veiled nuclear threat
saying Russia would use all means
necessary to defend its territory
blaming what he calls the satanic West
for provoking Russia's Invasion while at
the same time demanding Ukraine lay down
its arms and negotiate
Ukraine's Vladimir zielinski says he's
prepared to talk but only with a Putin's
successor the Ukrainian president met
moscow's illegal annexation with a move
likely to enrage the Russian leader a
formal request to fast-track Nato
membership we support Ukraine's rights
to choose its own its own path to decide
what kind of security Arrangements they
want to be a part of
Redmond that's a very pointed move from
zielinski of course it's a direct
response to Russia's attempted
annexation now all 30 NATO countries
would have to reach a consensus for
Ukraine to join but what would
membership mean for Canada and what
would it mean for the rest of the
alliance for our article 5 of NATO's
founding document promises that an
attack on one member is an attack on all
that would mean bringing Ukraine into
the fools could potentially bring the
entire Alliance directly into the fight
including Canada the US the UK Germany
and many others now Article 5 does not
require each country to take military
force each NATO member would decide for
itself what it wanted to do for example
a country could send equipment as many
are already doing thanks Redmond to the
U.S now where Ian has made its second
landfall this time in South Carolina Ian
hit is a category one hurricane it's now
being downgraded to a post-tropical
cyclone already there's major flooding
and extensive damage more than 2 200 000
people are without power and the storms
barreling North with the threat of more
high winds and Powerful storm surge and
of course Florida still coming to terms
with Ian's damage our Jackson prosco is
in hard hit Fort Myers a once pristine
place which now Jackson is in shambles
far given the scope of This Disaster
it's increasingly clear that it is going
to take Florida years to recover from
this today we travel to one of the
outlying islands that took a direct hit
from Hurricane Ian and what we found was
destruction in every direction the only
road to San Carlos island is covered in
debris homes and businesses were
obliterated with boats tossed onto dry
land
Dustin Zimmerman went looking for the
boat he calls home he found it far from
the ocean on the other side of the
highway this is your home what did you
think when you saw this for the first
time it's I I had it already in my mind
it was going to be something like this
Destin rode out the Storm at his
father's house in Naples today he's back
at the boat to see if anything can be
salvaged I'm so glad I didn't try to be
a tough guy out of it because I wouldn't
have won against mother nature mother
nature delivered the worst possible blow
to this part of Florida the community of
Fort Myers Beach is all but gone
Statewide dozens are dead or missing
many ignored evacuation orders and were
unable to escape a storm surge that was
nearly five meters high there's a lot of
people missing still that they don't
know
if they'll find them this is the
neighbor Magdalena Hager is worried
about her own friends and Neighbors
after her own close call three you can
see the water line she and her family
sheltered on the upper levels of her
father's house to escape the water the
water was
16 feet
and our level that we were on is at 17
feet the storm surge was so powerful it
blew out the stairs leaving them trapped
everything from the ground level is gone
if you went down to the Big Blue House
yeah in the front yard is a boat that's
ours after all that's been lost there's
a sense this part of Florida will be
forever changed by Hurricane Ian because
everything here was so nice and so
perfect this was Paradise and now it's
gone a disaster for the history books
that's still unfolding
the toll in terms of damage and lives
lost is still being assessed but already
there are suggestions that this could be
the costliest disaster in Florida
history with up to 50 billion dollars in
insured losses pharah thanks Jackson and
Ian could cost us here in Canada too and
gaviola explains how it's expected to
affect our country's Supply chains and
even your household budget
first came Fiona whose damage may go
down as the most expensive in Atlantic
Canada's history
well then in roared Ian the ninth named
storm of the Atlantic hurricane season
walloping Florida and parts of the
Eastern United States you may have been
spared a direct hit but you may still be
feeling the ripple effect on Supply
chains anything in the natural resource
sector in the uh on the east coast of
Canada would be affected consumer
impacts include extreme price spikes at
the pumps offsetting some of the relief
we've seen in recent weeks and higher
prices for food already the one-two
punch of Fiona and Ian has impacted Key
Florida crops including Citrus orange
juice Futures already jumped in price
this week meaning that glass of OJ will
likely cost you more soon you can also
expect to pay more for avocados and
other items we import from the Sunshine
State our weaker currency is an
inflationary Factor too because most
Goods affected are priced in U.S dollars
if you go elsewhere you have to
renegotiate new contracts and you're
going to likely to have to pay more to
import whatever you need and that will
actually impact retail prices eventually
supply chain snarls still exist but with
the loosening of covid restrictions
we're in a much better place overall
than we were last year in fact shipping
costs have come down about 50 percent in
the last six months and the cost of
trucking has decreased by about 20
percent the infrastructure shut down
like ports you know for a couple of days
highways can become impassable power
outages can shut down plants or
distribution centers for periods of time
this time supply chain analysts see
disruptions for days not weeks or months
and caviola Global News Toronto
students in Afghanistan ambushed
coming out the deadly attack at a
learning center
a suicide attack at a tutoring center in
Afghanistan has killed at least 19
people many of them female students and
injured dozens more
this witness says they were in the
middle of an exam when the explosion
happened he says the blast happened
between where the girls were sitting in
the front row with the boys behind them
girls high schools have been closed in
Kabul in recent months after the Taliban
backtracked on a promise to open all
schools but residents and education
workers have said that female students
have still been attending private
tutoring centers no one's claimed
responsibility for this attack but it
happened in a predominantly Hazara
neighborhood an ethnic minority group
targeted in the past by Ultra radical
groups
they call themselves Warriors against
violence ahead eliminating the epidemic
of Shame and abuse in indigenous
communities
the mass killings in Saskatchewan
earlier this month has drawn attention
to what some are calling an epidemic of
violence within indigenous communities
the cause is clear violence is a known
product of trauma the solution however
is more challenging Heather York's West
explains
twice a week the Warriors in this room
smudge before going into battle fighting
an all too familiar foe I'm the first
one in my family to not go to
residential school my grandmother my
mother and it's
I also want to be the first one in my
family to stop these generational
traumas and abuses I also would like to
pray this is a healing Circle put on by
The Warriors against violence but the
support here isn't specifically for
those who are victims of violence it's
also for those at greatest risk of
causing harm
on September 4th when a stabbing Rampage
beginning on the James Smith Cree Nation
took the lives of 10 people indigenous
communities across Canada experienced a
collective kind of recognition and pain
that's not an isolated event that event
was highly triggering for probably every
Community indigenous Community
across across these lands in many
indigenous communities the brutal Legacy
of Canada's residential school system
normalized violence for Generations
trauma visited upon children extending
to families fueled a cycle of trauma and
hurt often without any Community
Resources for people in desperate need
experiencing addiction and violence
people who have lived it say it simply
left too many struggling with anger they
couldn't control or contain I don't know
why it's always the ones that we love or
they love us that we always hurt this
more than anything is what the Warriors
here are fighting against violence
within communities carried out by
friends neighbors and family members an
outward continuation of deeply ingrained
hurt not so much bad things in my life
I was a victim of uh
verbal physical mental sexual abuse as
growing up as a child Vancouver based
and indigenous-led the organization has
been holding healing workshops for 25
years their success is measured by lives
changed and saved we do it in a way that
is more it's cultural and if it was our
own way of healing practices as
indigenous people it works referrals now
frequently come from the justice system
with requests for training from across
Canada and the United States Joyce
facilis says they are addressing a
critical need but they too require more
resources and support I feel a lot of
my ancestors with me when I'm in the
circle dedicating their lives to break
the cycle of intergenerational trauma in
others you're going to be teachers each
and every one of you one person at a
time
Heather urich's West Global News
turning home next the program helping
indigenous people reconnect with their
roots
there's a new program on BC's Sunshine
Coast and it's designed to help
indigenous people who have been
disconnected from their communities
return home
it was created by a woman who was
adopted at an early age and wasn't able
to confirm she was indigenous until she
was an adult Anita Garcia reports
it was at this very place the public
market in Gibson's BC seven years ago
that Charlene sejenko was gifted this
paddle featuring indigenous designs at a
fundraising event I felt this amazing
wave of emotion come over me and that
was actually the night that I decided I
needed to prove what I and I think I
intuitively knew senjenko says she
always knew she was different she grew
up with adoptive non-indigenous parents
who decided not to tell her she's First
Nations I think there's a feeling when
you you never get a chance to meet a
parent
it would be 50 years before she would
seek out that truth herself it was all
through paperwork I had to I I found my
adoption certificate my birth mom's name
it said her age which was 16 and it said
um just it just said Indian
below that it was a process that took
over three years she's among more than
150 children taken from split scene
between about 1960 and 1980 during the
60s scoop that was a significant portion
of the population of her home nation
leaving behind just 300 people in the
community it sparked a movement called
the Indian Child Caravan led by a man
also taken as a child from that same
community at that point in my life I was
13 years old I honestly thought about
taking my life so in that process I just
lost all hope his name is Wayne
Christian he's a former seven-term Chief
who through cultural healing practices
moved past the trauma and has now spent
most of his adult years advocating for
indigenous children and I was a big push
for taking control of our own child
welfare and her doctor in her own
legislation the only one encountered it
to this point that does what we're doing
seeing his work Charlene got in contact
with him last year and now the two are
working together to help others
reconnect with their communities by
hosting a healing event back here in
Gibsons called for the children
they're launching an initiative this
fall called our nation heals because
that's how you change the world
is through the children a full circle
moment for two survivors sent on very
different paths now coming together in
order to help others come home nitu
Garcia Global News Gibson's BC
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of this
important day with us we leave you
tonight with a look at four new Canada
post stamps the first one was expected
to be an annual series showcasing the
visions of First Nations Inuit and metis
artists for the future of Truth and
Reconciliation until tomorrow take care
of yourselves and each other good night
foreign